توماس دوران إنيد قسم شرطة أوكلاهوما
لقد كنت هنا منذ أسبوعين ، لقد
كنت ضابطًا في المجموع لمدة 12
عامًا تقريبًا ، تحذيرًا من أن ما توشك
على رؤيته قد يكون من الصعب جدًا مشاهدة
الضابط دوران يبدأ
شرطة إطلاق نار نشطة بشكل مكثف  التدريب
باستخدام جهاز محاكاة عالي التقنية
اشترى هذا القسم مؤخرًا
الأشخاص الذين ستراهم ممثلين مستأجرين ،
حسنًا ، أطلق الضابط دوران النار على هذا
في
المدرسة وهذه هي كل المعلومات التي لدينا
أنت هناك مع شريكيك
وأنت تعرفنا  السياسة
هي أننا ندخل ، لا ننتظر
أين هم
على الرغم من أنهم ممثلون يشاهدون
مشهد التدريب يتكشف
، تم إطلاق النار على شريك الضابط ديورانت ، ثم تم إطلاق
النار على المسلح من قبل نقيب دوران
وارين ويلسون ، وهو مدرب الضابط دوران ،
ونحن نعلم
أنك في المتوسط  حوالي شخص ميت واحد
كل 10 ثوانٍ من حالة إطلاق النار النشط ،
هناك نصر واحد على الأقل
كل 10 ثوانٍ ، لذلك لا يوجد وقت لانتظار
استمرار المحاكاة هناك
م 2  رماة الخام في مكتبة المدرسة
[موسيقى]
أسقطها
بعد كل سيناريو
يقدمه المدرب تقييمه نادرًا جدًا ، هل من النادر جدًا أن يقوم
الضباط الجدد
بضرب الخفاش فورًا بعمل جيد جدًا على ذلك ، ثم
بدأت على الفور في المسح مرة أخرى في
كل مرة
وإليك واحدًا آخر
لا نحصل عليه غالبًا في المرة الأولى ،
لذا فقد حصلت عليه من خلال المسح الضوئي ،
هل هناك أي نقطة شعرت فيها
أنك لا تستطيع تغطية كل شيء
آه لا لمجرد أنني قلت ربما
بسبب وقتي في
أه من خلال  التدريبات والمواقف التي مررت بها ،
اعتدت أن
أفعل إذا كان هناك أكثر من واحد
لديك تلك العقلية ، لذلك أنا معتاد على ذلك على
الرغم من أنك تعتقد أنك تعاملت مع
تهديد ، فلديك وعي 360
بنفسك  لذلك تحتاج إلى التأكد من أنك
تبحث عن المزيد
دائمًا من ضابط قسم الشرطة دائمًا
يتضمن تدريب دوران مواقع افتراضية أخرى
مثل المسرح حيث تكون الإستراتيجية
مماثلة لمدرسة
لا تنتظر الذهاب إليها
حيث يؤدي ذلك إلى
القضاء على التهديد
بعد الحصول عليه  لقد قام g بإطلاق النار على الضابط دوران فعل
ذلك بالضبط
، ثم في قاعة المحكمة
حيث يوجد مالكك في مكانهم ،
قام مرة أخرى بإزالة التهديد الذي
يخبره الكابتن ويلسون للضابط بأن
أول تدريب إطلاق نار نشط له مع قسمه الجديد
هو نجاح أنه اتخذ
قرارات جيدة أنه  استمر في البحث عن التهديدات ،
لقد كانت مهارته في الرماية على وشك الحدوث ، لقد قمت للتو
بعمل جيد جدًا في السيناريوهات التي أنا
فخور بها ، كما تم إخبار الضابط دوران أيضًا
بمستوى التوتر المرتفع ومعدل ضربات
القلب المتوقع مع هذا التدريب النابض بالحياة ،
هل تعتقد أنك
ضابط شرطة أفضل مما كان عليه عندما دخلت
هنا ،
نعم بالتأكيد بسبب هذا التدريب